lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo será
usar nuestro conocimiento de cálculo
para encontrar el área azul que vemos
aquí el área azul es la que se encuentra
entre bucles sucesivos de la gráfica
polar r de teta igual a 3 por theta seno
de teta esta gráfica está en coordenadas
polares para comprender lo que está
ocurriendo aquí vemos que este primer
bucle aparece cuando te estás se
encuentra entre 0 y 0 es menor o igual
que teta itt es menor o igual que cuando
teta es cero toda la función es cero y
conforme theta se incrementa nuestra
erre se incrementa también pero conforme
theta se acerca a pin
recordemos que seno de pi es cero
nuestra r se aproxima también a cero
pero cuando pasamos de p2p esperaríamos
ver que la gráfica estuviera por aquí
pero luego nos daríamos cuenta de que
cuando pasamos de pi a 2 pib el seno de
esos valores teta será negativo por lo
que hace que esto se invierta en lugar
de tener una r en el tercer cuadrante
cuando theta es un poco mayor a pi como
eres negativa se invierte y se mueve
hacia este lado así que cuando te traba
de p2p trazamos este bucle externo tiene
sentido que el radio se incremente
porque aquí tenemos este triste está
conforme aumenta theta también aumentará
la magnitud de r está r hubiera estado
aquí si el seno fuera positivo pero como
es negativo se mueve por acá y aumenta
su magnitud conforme theta aumenta con
esto en mente
veamos cómo podemos calcular esta área
en general cuando vemos una curva polar
y queremos encontrar el área lo
resolvemos con la integral definida de
teta igual a alfa a teta igual a beta y
recordando lo que vimos sobre esto en
vídeos anteriores esto es un medio por r
de teta al cuadrado de teta esta es la
fórmula general para calcular el área
dentro de una curva polar pero lo que
tratamos de hacer aquí es encontrar el
área de dos bucles sucesivos de una
curva polar cuando theta va de 0 a 2 pi
como hacemos esto 1
hacerlo es encontrar el área total del
bucle más grande y a este restarle el
área del bucle más pequeño si en algún
momento se sienten inspirados los invito
a que pausa en el vídeo y traten de
resolverlo por su cuenta siempre será
mejor que intenten resolverlo ustedes en
lugar de ver pasivamente cómo resuelvo
el vídeo cuál es el área del círculo más
grande sin tomar en cuenta este bucle
pequeño es la integral definida que va
de p2p de un medio por todo esto al
cuadrado tres tetas seno de teta al
cuadrado de teta con esto calculamos el
área del círculo externo
ahora vamos a restar el área del círculo
más pequeño cuáles son sus límites va de
cero a un medio por tres tetas seno de
teta al cuadrado detecta resulta que
estas integrales no son fáciles de
resolver por su cuenta pero contamos con
herramientas para resolverlas y se han
tomado clases avanzadas para los
exámenes ap se espera que ustedes usen
esas herramientas como calculadoras
gráficas
para resolver esto eso es lo que vamos a
hacer aquí usamos nuestro emulador de la
calculadora t 84 plus
vamos a usar las funciones matemáticas y
aquí abajo vemos la función de integral
definida elegimos esta función esta
calculadora nos muestra una
representación visual de la anotación de
la integral en otras calculadoras cuando
elegimos esta función nos muestra un
paréntesis en donde debemos escribir
indicamos con respecto a qué vamos a
integrar y cuáles son los límites pero
aquí es bastante obvio cómo ingresar los
datos recordemos que esta integral azul
va de pi a 2 espn
ponemos un medio que está multiplicando
aquí pondremos que integramos con
respecto a x así que a todas las tetas
las reemplazamos por equis para que sea
más fácil de escribir en la calculadora
escribimos 3x seno de equis y vamos a
elevar al cuadrado todo esto vamos a
agregar algunos paréntesis y ponemos
esto al cuadrado
esto lo integramos con respecto a x
esta es nuestra primera integral y a
esta le vamos a restar la integral
anaranjada usamos de nuevo nuestras
funciones matemáticas elegimos la
función de integral definida y ahora
nuestra integral va de 0 aquí escribimos
lo mismo que en la integral anterior un
medio por 3 por x seno de x ponemos
paréntesis para elevar todo esto al
cuadrado con respecto a x ya que
escribimos todo correctamente oprimimos
enter y obtenemos aproximadamente 139
punto 53 lo escribimos 139 punto 53
unidades cuadradas y con esto terminamos